new-yorkais durant la vague
Omicron parvient à des résultats
étonnants : une double dose
une infection.
Normand Grondin.
- Depuis novembre dernier,
plus de 60 % des jeunes
Québécois de 5 à 11 ans ont reçu
au moins une dose du vaccin
Trois mois plus tard, alors que
les masques vont bientôt tomber.
une étude américaine
vient semer le doute sur
la qualité de leur protection.
Selon l'étude, elle serait
presque nulle contre
l'infection au variant Omicron,
essentiellement pa
trop faible de vaccin.
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE, immunologue
Inst. de rech. cliniques de Mtl
- On a appris avec le temps,
c'est cepetite dose
qu'on donne aux 5 à 11 ans,
10 microgrammes,
c'est pas assez.
- L'étude compare l'efficacité
deux grodeux grodeux grodeux gr,
les 12 à 17 ans et les 5 à 11,d,
à mesure que le variant
progressait, l'efficacité
du vaccin chez les 12-17
a diminuChez les 5 à 11 ans,
elle a chuté brutalement,
de 68 à seulement 12 % .
- Je pense qu'il y a un effet
chez les 5 à 11 ans et le fait
e c'est juste un vaccin
de deux doses, alors qu'il y a
de plus en plus d'évidence qARN,
vaccins contre la COVID, c'est
des vaccins de trois doses.
- La bonne nouvelle : le vac
continue d'offrir aux enfants
une importante protection
de plus de 70 %.
Mais chez les jeun
scolaire, on le recommande avant
tout pour éviter l'infection.
- D'enlever les masques
à la vitesse qu'on va
de la... semaine de relâche,
je pense que... on se doutai
avant que c'était probablement
trop vite, puis je pense
c'est une confirmation que
c'est probablement.
- À la santé publique du
de l'étude.Dr GASTON DE SERRES,t
national de santé publique du Qc
- Je pense que le e de
ces résultats-là parce
qu'évidemment, si l'efficacité
est basse, ça veut dire
qu'en en
plus de transmission.
- Par contre, pas question
de modifier le programme
- Je pense pas que
les résultats de cette étude
vont changer la stratégie.
Je crois absolument pas qu'on va
aller veoisième dose de
vaccin pour les enfants.Maintené
sur l'immunisation qui décidera.
- L'étude américaine est basonon
de jeunes New-Yorkais
de 5 à
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal